this is a production of Cornell
University
today I'm going to be talking about tea
and the taste of climate change I've
been studying the tea system since 2006
for me t is a really interesting way to
examine human interactions with the
environment because it is a plant system
that humans have managed for hundreds if
not thousands of years and I'm
specifically focusing on the impacts of
climate change on T as we know climate
changes impacting our ecosystems and
farmer livelihoods as well as the health
benefits consumers get from agricultural
products around the world for example a
longer frost-free growing season can
help increase the production of specific
crops and as previous scholars have
shown this really depends where you are
located geographically in the world and
it also depends on the specific crop
that you're speaking about whether it's
rice or soy each plant behaves
differently and most previous scholars
have documented or focused on looking at
the impact of climate change on crop
yield this is relatively well documented
and what my study focuses on with my
collaborators is looking at the impact
of climate change on crop quality which
is a lot less acknowledged and the way I
am looking at this is through a couple
of natural and human systems approach
where we have our natural system of
biotic and abiotic factors and then we
have our human system of traders and
consumers and farmers and sort of the
link between that is the accurate agri
ecosystem or our food production system
and the feedback loop between the
natural system and the human system that
I'm focusing on in addition to yield is
really crop quality and then the way
that the human system sort of takes that
response and then feeds into the natural
system is through their actual
adaptation and managed
men of agroecosystems and then obviously
these are eco systems do not exist on
their own they're impacted by exogenous
change such as climate change policies
as well as markets and so that's sort of
the overall socio ecological system
which I'm looking at and really a focus
on crop quality and crop quality is
important as I mentioned before because
it's not only yields that are important
for food security or for the amount of
money farmers receive from selling crops
it's also the actual quality of those
products so if you're thinking about all
of these sort of diverse fruits and
vegetables it's not only calories but
it's also the micronutrients and these
micronutrients vary based on management
of the agro ecosystem for example a
carrot grown in an organic system versus
a carrot grown in the conventional
system may have varying levels of the
secondary metabolites that provide the
main health benefits from consuming
these carrots and so if you're consuming
a carrot that has relatively low
concentrations of these secondary
metabolites you're also not going to be
getting the same health benefits and
have to consume more off the same
product and so I've sort of taken that
framework and applied it to looking at
the chi system to see the impacts on T
in my study but really thinking about
botanical quality more broadly of both
food and medicinal plants which are
central to ethnobotanical systems so the
overall objective and most study is to
provide quantitative data how and why t
qualities vulnerable to changing climate
conditions and that's at the natural
level of the system and then the
resulting linkages to the social system
both economic as well as cultural so I'm
just going to go through the main
objectives of this study
and today I'm going to share how climate
is impacting T quality and yield I'm
going to share some data from field
sampling as well as manipulative
greenhouse experiments so i've been
using extreme climate events in the
field as a proxy measure for climate
events that are supposed to become more
prevalent with climate change and of
course is a lot of confounded factors
that occur with field sampling and so
i'm also coupling that with manipulative
greenhouse experiments that mimic
climate predicted or expected climate
factors and then i'm bringing those
samples back to the lab to look at the
phytochemical variation the second
objective is then to take those same tea
samples and see the way the consumers
are responding to that variation
secondary metabolite chemistry through
sensory analysis and my collaborative
team we're also doing agricultural
economics modeling to look at how
climate variables are impacting yields
on a larger scale and the third
objective is looking at the way farmers
are responding to variations of climate
variability in their t systems both
based on their direct observation as
well as the way they are responding to
markets so if consumers are perceiving
sensory variation and T how does that
impact consumer buying decisions and
then how does that impact the way
farmers are managing their
agroecosystems and what decisions are
they're making based on consumer
responses and then finally the goal is
to take all of this varied
socio-ecological Zeta and to construct a
model where we will be able to simulate
the response of T quality to variable
climate factors and the goal of this is
to develop plans and policies that we
can provide to tea farmers and land use
manager
to better adapt and mitigate for climate
change so when I'm talking about tea I'm
specifically talking about camellia
sinensis and the CAC family that is the
commercial source for all white green
oolong black and polarity so it comes
from this one single species and it's
the variation in the processing that
results in this diversity of flavor
profiles that we get but it is from the
same species and camellia sinensis has
two main cultivars or two main varieties
excuse me the census variety which is a
small leaf or variety that grows in more
temperate areas and the Islamic of
variety which is the broadleaf variety
which is considered the original variety
that grows in tropical and subtropical
areas and in addition to those varieties
there's also a lot of diversity with
lots of farmer land braces and cultivars
the reason particularly new nan province
in southwestern China which is
considered the birthplace of the tea
plant so you don borders Myanmar Vietnam
and Laos and in this area you see not
just camellia sinensis growing in the
wild but also 11 other species that are
closely related to camellia sentences
that farmers use the German possum in
their tea systems for introgression
resulting in a lot of genetic diversity
and having this area be sort of the
center of genetic diversity for the tea
plans these are a few farmer landraces
so with my background I would say these
are all camellia sinensis for radius
tomica and DNA barcoding would confirm
that however the farmers that I work
with in Yunnan have a different name for
each of these different land races and
they also have different sensory
attributes or uses for these even though
I'm saying they're all camellia sinensis
for radius tomica there's a lot deeper
ecological knowledge and use by the
farmers that are managing these systems
and they may
have 15 to 20 different landraces of tea
within a single tea garden of just the
hecht are so a lot of diversity if you
sort of compare that to our main food
crops in the world it's really
fascinating to see why and how farmers
manage this diversity and so tea plants
can you know tea leaves can go to
different sizes imagine one of these tea
leaves and furling in your tea cup and
that probably wouldn't happen so much
over here because usually when teas
commercialized it's the young the new
bud and d jacent two leaves are the
harvest units for commercialization
however in indigenous communities that
have been managing tea for hundreds of
years farmers do harvest the older
leaves which they used to make tonics
for immune boosting and nuts this is an
example of that harvest so T in its
native state grows to be a tall tree
about 15 to 20 meters tall and it grows
in these beautiful biodiverse forest in
southern Yunnan into northeastern India
in Burma and Laos and then with human
management that sort of traditional
forest system has transitioned so this
over here is a tiara forest it still
looks a lot like a forest system however
it's been intensified for tea production
and some of the woody plant species have
been removed for the system however a
lot of food and medicinal plants are
still maintained I had done an inventory
of about 20 meter by 20 meter plots and
I found over 200 food and medicinal
plants that were conserved within the
space by the community for various needs
this over here is a mixed crop system
and it has tea and it's intercrop with
grains however tea in most parts of the
world grows in monocultural Terrace
plantations really for consistent
product in high yield and so there's a
lot of different management and
obviously based on the different
management the phytochemical qualities
of tea also vary
and just another note on the management
of these systems and agroforestry lying
on a forest structure does it need to
have agrochemical inputs like pesticides
and fertilizers because it's relying
that ecosystem services provided by the
forest structure whereas monoculture
plantations even if they're organic
generally have agrochemical input of
pesticides and herbicides etc and as I
mentioned we're not necessarily
consuming teper in large quantities for
yield it really depends on the quality
on so if you're black black tea drinker
versus a green tea drinker that
variation is because of the change in
chemistry that occurred during
processing you might buy high mountain
teas versus low mountain tease because
you really have a preference for
specific phytochemistry so the main
phytochemicals perty that gave its
health benefits of the polyphenols with
egcg being sort of a star antioxidant
compound which has gotten a lot of press
an advertisement and all those different
phytochemicals including the polyphenols
and methyl xanthine caffeine which gives
stimulant properties theanine which
makes tea sort of a relaxant all of
these have a specific taste which
consumers are able to perceive such as
bitter sweet or bitter and sweet and
this really varies again as I mentioned
with environmental management and just a
little note over here on the bottom the
show sort of the evolution of tea the
historic use of tea was is considered to
have been medicine and sort of
transitioned from medicine to a tonic
and eventually to a beverage tea leaves
are consumed as a food in some parts of
the world sort of like a like a salad
and tea I find it a really compelling
study system because it is the most
consumed beverage in the world after
water
has really quite widespread utilization
there's hundreds of years of management
and it also plays an important role in
public health because it provides a
notable source of antioxidant by the
chemicals and these are linked to
different benefits in the human body
such as anti-inflammatory prevention
against cancer as well as for
cardiovascular health so T was
traditionally sort of this the center of
diversity as I mentioned was in southern
Yunnan which is over here and because of
these health benefits provided by T it
became requested or demanded in
communities that couldn't grow it's over
here this red line basically is the tea
horse road which is the book that dr. of
our vigas had showed and this is the
oldest tea trade route of in the world
and over here this is the Tibetan
Plateau this is Lhasa over here and
communities in the Tibetan Plateau live
in pretty harsh conditions where it's
really hard to grow fruits and
vegetables and they came to utilize tea
as a substitute for fruits and
vegetables and that really is what's for
the creation off this old historic road
which not only was t traded but lots of
other spices E and medicines and and
that was sort of the first spread of tea
and then as more and more communities
began to know of tea and it was really
through Buddhist monks that spread the
consumption of tea more and more people
began to incorporate into their daily
routine
so I'm just going to share some
photographs from the tea horse road to
give you a better cultural context of
this area this is Annika village as a to
farming community in southern Yunnan
where I've been working since 2006 and
just some pictures of the tea horse road
itself
so the last picture is t being consumed
by Tibetan household and it's been
churned with butter yak butter
specifically so this is yak butter tea
has anybody tried yak butter tea yeah
how what's the flavor profile for you
acquired taste and so I was mentioning
earlier how the quality of T varies on
based on environmental conditions and
this is just one example if T is
harvested from a low elevation versus
sort of at the top of the mountain data
suggest that there is phytochemical
variation and this is why a lot of
consumers seek out high mountain teas as
also the prices of those are notably
higher again we're looking at the
geographers versus a monoculture and
some of the work that I had done for my
doctoral dissertation was to sort of
analyze the difference of the
phytochemical variation so this is a
Nagra forest in an aqua community and
this is a monoculture plantation nearby
at the same elevation and we found that
there was more than twice the amount of
key catechin compounds 40 procured from
the Agri forest and this may be because
of many reasons they may be because
there's a lot more pests pressures in a
[ __ ] forest or because of shade trees
or because of the height of tree so a
lot of different factors which ramallah
cific mechanism through greenhouse
studies hmmm Oh catechins are probably
phenolic compounds that provide
antioxidant activity in humans so it's
sort of the link to the health benefits
of green tea
and these so this is just the variation
based on the production system and then
based on geographic region or the
specific specific cultivar the
photochemical was also very NT so in
blue here we have all the different sort
of tea producing areas within China and
then as I mentioned before when you
process tea from white tea to black tea
or post fermented purity there's also a
change in by the chemicals based on all
the different processing factors so the
main processing happens once T is
harvested is steaming it or pan frying
it and this is to deactivate the
polyphenol oxidase that oxidizes the
catechin compounds rolling it to break
down the cell walls and remove moisture
content and then drying it and this
really helps preserve the health
compounds attributed to the different
teas and then variation in these
different processes results in all of
these different types of tea and my
previous work has shown as well as that
by a lot of other scientists that
consumers can perceive changes in T
secondary metabolites and so this is a
ranking of t100 if n cheese and the more
the less intensely rated teas also had
lower amounts of catechins as well as
the methyl xanthine caffeine and now i'm
going to talk about the cup of tea that
specifically drove my research on the
impacts of climate change in T this is
during one of my first few seasons in
2007 and I was in a acha household
drinking tea after a long day of
ecological sampling and then I returned
to that same house about three days
later and the East Asian monsoon had hit
and we were drinking tea again and the
head of the household female says it has
changed the taste has changed and I was
really curious what she meant and then
our husband also drank the tea and he
also confirmed that the tea
had changed and what they were referring
to was at the east asian monsoon had hit
until they had sort of transitioned from
a spring harvest to a monsoon harvest
which is really attributed to when the
rains come and and then quality drops
notably and the prices farmers get for
their tea also drops and then when the
autumn harvest is basically determined
by the retrieval of the East Asian
monsoon and at this stage the quality's
perceived to increase as well as the
prices that farmers get for their tea so
it really is an issue just not just of
the phytochemicals that we are consuming
but also the livelihoods that farmers
are getting from their crop and after
her husband tested the t he determined
the price to be about half of that of
the spring harvest and this is just some
data showing how there's a drop in
prices on based on the different seasons
and that really made me start thinking
about the role that precipitation has in
T quality and what does this mean with
increase or decrease precipitation
that's occurring with climate change and
so the central tenet of my study is sort
of looking at T as an indicator species
for climate change and what this can
tell us about other plans that we're
using specifically for the leaf and then
thinking about taste as a sensor of
climate change and its effects on you
food quality so really thinking about
the individual consumer and the role
that they're playing in sense and
climate change based on taste and now
I'm going to share some data from the
natural side component of this study and
so for the field sampling I am working
with my collaborators and we're sampling
at three different sites in China or
three different regions in China which
are different sort of kind of capture
the different climatic conditions of
major tea producing areas in China I'm
at each site we have or location we have
two sites high elevation and low
elevation site we try to choose the
elevations to be somewhat the same and
also the cultivar that's in each of
those systems is also we've accounted
for and we're sampling basically from
2012 till 2016 so it's a five year study
and you know in multiple seasons within
the year and the goal eventually is then
to take all of the data on T quality
needles from these five years and these
six different locations and combine them
to eventually construct our model so I'm
going to share data from one of our
sampling years and this is our very
first sampling year and so this was
taken in just one location where we
sample basically across 15 days during
an extreme drought period as well as the
onset of the monsoon and then during an
extreme monsoon period and over here
we're looking at the response of leaf
biomass from during the drought to the
monsoon so we see an increase in both
leaf length as well as weight and then
concurrently there is a significant
reduction in secondary metabolite
concentrations from the spring drought
to the monsoon so the major antioxidant
compounds that determine tea quality
were shown to decrease and that work I
did in the lab using hplc as well as
some basic bioassays and antioxidant
assays I'm not a chemist and so that's
why I find collaboration really to be
the spice of life and very promising and
fulfilling in my research and some
collaborating with some chemists who are
experts on at GC GC ms and so they also
are looking at the same samples where
they've developed this really
comprehensive t library and
they're looking at the specific
volatiles or aroma compounds that
determined equality and they also found
that there were a few more aroma
compounds in the spring samples or the
drought samples compared to the monsoon
samples and so we found an inverse
relationship overall in terms of our
leaf wait to secondary metabolite
concentrations and this suggests either
a dilution effect and or water stress to
the plant and what is this sort of mean
that was just a seasonal study so what
does this sort of mean for larger
climate change looking at precipitation
in the field site shows that there
really has been historically this looks
at data from 1982 2010 there really
historically has been this variation of
precipitation throughout the year and
overall there seems to be a downward
trend in precipitation at the study site
would suggest that key quality could
actually be getting better with climate
change however plans to have their
threshold as we know and so
precipitation becomes too low this may
just be detrimental to the plant overall
and then looking at that was sort of
annual precipitation and now looking at
seasonal participation overall spring
precipitation has increased since 1970
about fifteen to twenty percent of the
study site and then at the same time
monsoon precipitation has also increased
and the the decrease in precipitation
was during the autumn season and that's
when farmers are not harvesting as much
tea and then looking into the future
future climate scenarios for the 2050 to
2070 nine period shows that
precipitation is expected
to decrease during the spring season so
again perhaps this may impact key
quality positively if it doesn't cross
the plant threshold and then during the
monsoon season is supposed to be getting
wetter and so basically farmers are
going to be seeing variable impacts on
their t systems and that was only just
for one year sampling at one study site
and our goal is to take that sort of
couples climate and t quality data for
five years add these six locations
towards really having a better
understanding and making a stronger
statement off climate effects on T
quality and I had also only shown data
from one site and this is looking at tea
production across China and this is
looking at temperature so there's been
an upper trend of temperatures in all
tea producing sites in China there's
also been while temperatures are
increasing precipitation overall and tea
producing sites in China is decreasing
and then overall yields have been
increasing and this is taking into
consideration any changes in technology
for tea production and in the field
we've only sort of looked at
precipitation and temperature however
there's multiple dynamics that are
happening of course in agroecosystems
and farmers are reporting for example
changes in pest pressures on different
weeds and then changes in pollination
dynamics within their systems so in the
future we plan to look at these a little
bit more carefully and we're going to be
doing that also in manipulative
greenhouse experiments and I find these
experiments really wonderful to engage
undergraduate students because we don't
have to take students all the way to
China which is also a great thing to do
but we can also have a little tea
plantation right there in the greenhouse
and one of the undergraduate research
projects looking at different variables
actually found that the interaction of
herbivory with precipitation offset the
increased precipitation and so when
we're just looking at a single climate
variable we may have one conclusion but
when we actually look at the
interactions that are happening with in
agroecosystems one effect may offset
another effect and interestingly some
farmers are accounting for pests as a
promising strategy for when their booty
quality decreases so there's a specific
tea that grows in Taiwan and with the
increased precipitation that's happening
during the monsoon season the quality is
considered solo however past pressures
are also increasing in that area and
instead of putting pesticides as farmers
usually do they're now actually letting
the pest proliferate in their Tiago
ecosystems because it sort of results in
a different change in secondary
metabolite chemistry and actually giving
that Tia slightly peach your honey like
flavor and so these are all these
different sort of adaptation strategies
that farmers are taking on in response
to climate change or climate variation
and now i'm going to share some data
from the human system so one thing that
one of the major components will do
sensory analyses and i don't have the
data to share right now but i wanted to
show the different types of sensory
analysis that we're doing so we're
actually going to be speaking to five
different populations since there is a
lot of human variation and cultural
variation on the way we respond or
perceive taste and our preferences so
one population RT farmers traders and
connoisseurs in China another one is an
expert T panel at the TV's Institute of
China that's been trained to really
measure T quality and then we are
coupling this with T populations in the
United States one is a tea panel at
Tufts University
and then Western T consumers and Western
T experts so really getting a diverse
group of consumers to see maybe only tea
farmers and tea experts are able to
perceive this difference maybe Western
consumers aren't or maybe they are so
these are sort of the experiments that
we're doing right now to see how notable
or who's actually able to discern these
changes inside the chemical quality and
another major component of the research
is really looking at the way farmers are
perceiving climate impacts on their
t-systems so I'm going to share some a
little bit of information from three
sites in the boolong mountains of
southwestern China where I conducted
semi-structured surveys with three
different indigenous groups the belong
de la la who and the aqha and then I
took that survey data and carried out
cultural consensus analysis to look at
variation within a community in between
communities and these are some overall
patterns that we have seen farmers are
reporting that there is increased
rainfall on unpredictability as well as
increased temperatures and farmers are
also saying that they really perceive
that rain impacts T quality however
they're not really sure how temperatures
increase or impact t quality and that's
some information that perhaps our T
project will be able to show and within
these two different indigenous groups
that all are in the blue on mountains we
did find high degree of informant
agreement on the effects of climate
change more recently I've started to
interview tea farmers and that aren't
that don't own the land or these three
indigenous communities of in managing
Tiago ecosystems other communities have
for hundreds of years so they really
have this ecological knowledge that has
been passed down and more recently in
eastern China band
interviewing tea farmers that are more
landless laborers that have only been
some of them only recently introduces
tea system and they have a very
different understanding of the way
climate is impacting their tea systems
so it's not that all farmers are aware
of this I'm really seeing that it's you
know the indigenous farmers have a very
different understanding compares to
farmers that have not necessarily
managed in a great ecosystem for that
long and the farmers you know that do
that are aware of it are also very
concerned on the impact that it has on
tea prices so we're seeing this inverse
relationship of precipitation and tea
price historically and so how our farmer
is responding to these different changes
over here I've sort of summarized from
the coding of the data some of the
different farmer responses to climate
change so some farmers have started to
substitute different varieties and make
their tea gardens more diverse others
are actually planting other crops just
so they aren't putting all their eggs in
one basket there is some modification of
the environment with technology and
management for example in places where
they have really intense droughts
farmers are starting to think about
having irrigation systems I had
mentioned the example of letting pests
proliferate in the field there's also
alteration of post-harvest processing
and so during processing you can really
also change the chemistry so some teas
that were historically processes green
teas are now being processed as Long's
or blacks where they're really taking
advantage of processing to invention the
flavor there's also some repurposing of
the end use of the product and overall
in certain communities people are very
active in sort of thinking about how to
market their products differently and
then
and some communities people are
abandoning their t systems or they're
relocating the locations maybe to higher
elevations in the mountain which they
perceive as having or being more
resilient to climate effects and so I
previously had talked about these two
different systems geographers entity
monoculture and a lot of the farmers who
do manage both systems this this
monoculture system has really been
promoted throughout China through
government extension the green for green
program or policy actually gave farmers
incentives to have the sort of system
and so in some communities you see
farmers managing both in agri forest as
well as a monoculture plantation and the
farmers that manage both will say how
the Agri forests are more resilient to
different climate variation that happens
from year to year or from season to
season and so looking at the drop in T
quality there was a slightly smaller
drop or notably smaller drop in T
quality for agri forest compared to the
monoculture and this is only sampling
over one year so we're going to be
continuing this to see this trend up
holes in more sites and agri for us also
you know provide a lot more economic
benefits to farmers so this the blue
line over here is looking at the market
price on this field site 40 from a Nagra
forest and the orange is looking at
during the same season price for
pterosaur monocultural plantation t so
farmers really do have an economic
incentive not just an ecological
incentive to grow this to grote niagara
forests and then some of my previous
work also showed that agri forests have
a little bit more genetic diversity or
notably more genetic diversity than then
terrace plantations and so taking all of
this all of this information that I
presented today just having you think as
an audience of the role of taste as a
sensor of climate change and I'm not
sure you personally or have had
relatives or friends say that oh this
fruit or vegetable used to taste really
different before when I was younger and
some of that might have to do on perhaps
of the way it's cultivated or some of
that might actually have to do with
climate variables so just something to
think about and then specifically I'm
thinking about Chi is an indicator
species of climate change but what other
crops can we look at to be an indicator
species for climate change and then the
role of adaptive capacity and determine
the extent of climate effects and so
there's one body of work that really
focuses on mitigating climate change and
the other work that really focuses on
adapting to climate change so what would
it mean for sustainability if
monoculture plantations I'm transitioned
to systems like this and overall I've
been starting to use this coupled model
to look at other systems as well not
just T quality so I leave you with a few
questions its climate change changing
the taste and quality of our favorite
and or local foods and what does this
mean for farmer livelihoods and what
does it mean for the health benefits
that we derived from the specialty crops
and for food security and more recently
as I've been expanding my research using
the socio-ecological model I've started
to look at the impact of climate change
on maple syrup quality and I know
there's some really great research
happening here at Cornell on looking at
the impacts of climate change on maple
syrup and recently my collaborators and
I got a USGS grant to look at this which
is specifically focusing on
and the impacts on quality versus yield
and then in Montana where I teach I'm
also starting to look at two new systems
which are huckleberries and fat head
cherries which are to agricultural
products that the state really prizes
for its cultural identity and so I just
want to thank you as an audience for
being here today and thank you so much
dr. Rodriguez for hosting me anti-terror
for all the coordination of this event
and also wanted to acknowledge my
collaborators it's a very
interdisciplinary collaborative project
and that's very much determines the
nature of my work on students and
undergraduate students are huge parts of
the research as are the farming
communities that I work with and then of
course the national science foundation
for making the work possible thank you a
change in the taste of tea that's like
15 years agree team enough for the
better and I'm cured while maybe its
climate change but I our accuracy does
it come from different places what's
visible to us here now yeah it used to
come from it not come from our less
tasty places so my work it for the
United States tea has started to come
South America Argentina as well as in
Africa so a lot more tea is being sort
of be directed from Asia to new tea
producing areas so that could be one
reason it's just like a change in
geographic location could be one factor
and I guess also from where um companies
are forcing the quality visit either
sourcing
pm desteni some learning the ribs of a
cancer of the esophagus was very high
again in China and it was partly created
to the teeth for a Greek again if I
liked the way they prepare it is aching
extremely hot water is that be there
right so it really depends on the
specific type of tea but a lot of times
of people are on the go though the
scribes are the hot water of TV's into
if there was and if people are for
bringing me home it's usually not like
that so there is a lot a lot of
population that's sort of drinks tea
where the water is really hot
basically that cruises weather because
it dragon he's so hot plus of course the
catechins themselves which should be
quite damaging so I'm just wondering
whether you did see a high rates of
cancer on this team drink return for
example I know in first um in the
communities that I work but they really
don't have a prevalence of cancer yeah
and and it's not really something that's
come up in my music I'm not actually
very familiar with that specific study
but overall I would say the
meta-analysis and reviews have been done
on tell that it's of tea um usually have
shown that it's and beneficial for
various health outcomes obviously
depends on cancer someone actually
really
I want to get a knock or whatever you
call milk is actually very beneficial to
the fact that it that's that's why
they're pricks you know in the end and
milk and who that's great cancer of the
esophagus he was pretty creative
integrity was precipitated some of the
catechins toxic so I was wondering
whether yes that's interesting is our
most of the catechins are linked to the
health benefits of teeth so i would have
to
um while your data shows that there are
changes in precipitation patterns during
the monsoon season monsoons have always
happened so I would assume that the
quality and therefore the price of tea
harvested during or after the monsoon
has traditionally dropped for farmers
yeah so I think it's always there's
always been sort of a variation and it's
sort of now seems that the variations
becoming larger with more variation
impact event so it is something that's
always happened but it seems like it
should commit a little bit more patience
a natural force
tenfold what is driving this very high
price for the agroforestry day
you see this difference when you knew
your GC mass spectrum absolutely so the
about more than ninety nine percent of
the teeth produced in the world is in
terrace plantation so it's less than one
person
so one is just implied very low supply
is very little out of course t it's a
system that's really going to place in
the last 50 yards and so spies really
little and you can't just create an ad
for us overnight so even though multiple
presentations carrots are might see all
that's really attractive you can't
suddenly have something so nice in your
system so what a one of those useless
value p what are the purchases valuing
what public right and ten more fragment
I know it's scarcely but okay most
people won't do like this cuz it scares
like this something they must be
appreciated right so I didn't briefly
show so the chief difference in that
fire chemicals these are just
and that are attributed to the flavor
come from and so the flavors a lot more
intense from an artist forest and you
can deck IV definitely perceive it one
of the indicators is really nice quality
teeth you don't have a GC GC for hplc in
your kitchen is the taste lingers a lot
more when you have achievement I before
it's it's called gone and I really high
quality tea might have that funny like
geez back of your throat for more than
an hour and so you can sort of resonates
for a while I and so that was woman and
second one is around thousand to two
thousand three as you can see the price
of agri forest he also have to always
been saying it's really a tree
two over here so there's an increasing
and impact retweet 2002-2003 on there
were lots of horses I'm on
of health as a health effects of farm
picking chi physiological responses in
their attitude pesticides herbicides in
tea plantations so it was really doing a
theory that people began to sort out the
gamma Chi on envy our forests have
absolutely no chemical input and so um
it was really in case a lot better and
then people felt safer um and then tease
you could you know there's hot outside
it makes your throats who filled rise at
about what what does the TCC value for Y
T versus a long
the values so we're really excited I'm
not a study looking at is a lot of
variation on T so it not all white 2 g's
ever saying that all sweetie the same
out who long for the same within let's
say just one type of like she likes over
you know depending on the manufacturer
and how long they are there's
significant variation I'm so out of the
main consentida great after six months
so those of you who have a positive T
that you can storing remember fresh is
best unless it's who are key which
actually supposed to get better age
what's the best way to spawn right so
it's sort of the traditional things for
his own kind of chemicals which is sort
of a cool temperature removing is looked
at the error so have a nice seal on
container if you have a bag I usually
sort of like
as possible if it's their really big
continues with a little bit of cheek
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu